their strategy's been all or nothing
and so struggling americans have of
course got
nothing well we're down to the wire
madam president
down to the wire the light at the end of
the tunnel
is in sight operation warp speed seems
poised to deliver vaccines on
an historic almost miraculous timetable
we have seen some hopeful signs of
engagement from our democratic
colleagues
but we have no reason to think the
underlying disagreements about policy
are going to evaporate
overnight
republicans and democrats do not need to
resolve every one of our differences to
get badly needed relief
out the door we just need both sides to
finally do what members of congress do
when they're serious
when they're serious about wanting an
outcome
drop the all or nothing tactics
drop the hostage taking and make law
in the many places where we have common
ground
that's what the country is counting on
that's how we can do right by the
american people before christmas
so let's get it done unfortunately
our efforts to pass another emergency
relief bill through the senate
have been stalled until now for one
reason the republican leader
has refused to compromise again today
we heard the same old song from the
republican leader
his position has not budged since march
first he put the senate on pause while
the spread of the virus got worse and
worse
then after pressure mounted the
republican leader finally decided to put
forward a series of bills that
compromised
only the things that the republicans
want
while the nation has been clamoring for
a bipartisan solution
the senate under the leadership of the
republican leader
has only been allowed to vote on
partisan republican proposals
each of which has been sorely inadequate
and each of which
has contained poison pills designed to
ensure the bill's failure
the republican leader never mentions
those poison pills in his speeches to
this chamber
where he excoriates democrats for
refusing to pass quote bipartisan
legislation that everyone agrees on
but bipartisan does not mean democrats
must agree to whatever the republican
leader wants
or whatever issues he picks
the biggest stories the moment they
happen from around the globe subscribe
to boomer quick take now for insight in
an instant